un proceso judicial que esperó seis años
y comenzó sin la presencia de su acusado
más notorio en versalles inició el
juicio contra karim benzema quien fue
denunciado por intento de chantaje a su
ex compañero en la selección francesa
mathieu valbuena un episodio oscuro que
el ahora jugador de olympiacos espera
superar pronto
todo el mundo está aquí o casi porque
cariño esta es una lástima pero es así y
seguiremos hasta el final hemos esperado
seis años para dejar esto detrás y nos
quedaremos el tiempo necesario para
hacerlo
en 2015 cuando compartían una
concentración en francia- benzema le
habría dicho a valbuena que existía un
vídeo de contenido sexual y le habría
ofrecido ponerle en contacto con un
amigo que podía ayudarlo pero valbuena
recuerda la interacción de otra manera
en la firma que recibió una llamada
anónima sobre la grabación y que la
persona le sugirió llegar a un acuerdo
esa llamada llevó al extremo a creer que
benzema estaba involucrado y más tarde
esa noche el delantero del real madrid
fue grabado en una llamada telefónica
diciendo valbuena toma en serio además
de benzema hay otros cuatro acusados de
formar parte de la trama uno de ellos se
negó la presunta extorsión fue una broma
se los prometo porque si realmente
hubiera querido vender el vídeo no se lo
hubiera mostrado a todo el mundo no
hubiera hablado con nadie no hubiera
escondido y podría haber hecho algo con
él pero se lo mostré a todos benzema ha
negado las acusaciones pero enfrenta
cargos por complicidad en un intento de
chantaje si es hallado culpable podría
recibir hasta cinco años de cárcel